oh my god  oh my god  oh my god we deserve this effect we  deserve to deserve this we deserve this  so much oh my goodness the academy thank  you guys for finding the academy finally  recognizing the academy helens this has  been a long time coming  is that bobby d over there oh my god  it's bobby dude  oh p  p the good fellow you're my inspirations  is that soups that matt ramos that's  matt rodriguez let's do it it's eric  vasso oh my god oh my goodness pewdiepie  is here  if it wasn't for you saying let's do it  we wouldn't have done it we wouldn't  have done it we would have done it we  need that kind of motivation i want to  thank my family for never believing in  me  because your doubts made me believe in  myself yes and i would like to thank  everybody who ever picked on me or  called me an idiot because i really in  turn alive deserved it but we put it  into our heart right but it's our art  art is agony and thank you for always  putting us in pain